hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the air things masters knockout phase
between daniel dubois and magnus carlson
uh so this is again the second day and
dubo is leading by one point margin
double won game one a game two ended in
a draw even though carlson was
really pushing for the win but dubo was
able to equalize in the end
and now we enter game three and this is
i know you i know you guys think it's
impossible but this is the craziest game
so far
and as you can imagine uh from the title
of the video also the title comes from a
gentleman named dinkar on twitter
so thank you for suggesting such a such
a wonderful title
i hope it does this game justice but i
don't think it does this is it
this is quite the game uh so without
further ado let's check it out
there's a plenty to cover so like in
game one they are repeating the moves up
to a certain point so dubo opens the
game with the d4
sorry about that uh we have knight to f6
for magnus
same as in game one uh c4 e6 knight to
f3 and the d5 again we have the queen's
gambit decline on the board
g3 and the bishop to b for check we have
knight beat to d2
so everything the same as in game one
however in game one uh we had castle
here from magnus but here he goes
d captures on c4 so now it's a different
game from game one
uh bishop to g2 do both prepares the
castle and now
again a5 from magnus with a3 challenging
carlson's bishop
and here carlson grabs it bishop
captures on b2 bishop characters and now
b5 so creating this very nice pawn chain
on the queen side
and since magnus is down already uh by
one point in the match he wants to play
for a win but he also
uh wants to keep it solid as if if the
game ends in a draw then he will have
his chance in the game for with the
white pieces again and here
although you kind of want to take
advantage of this there is no
real way you can do this even if you do
some sort of a discovery the rook can
just move it's not it's not a problem
and there are some games where b3 was
played but here
a4 by duboff is a new move so already as
of move 9 we have a completely new game
and uh it's a very often case when you
play
the queen's game with the client with
black you will have a nice punch and on
the queen side and the white will always
undermine it with moves like
a4 and b3 so here c6 defending that pawn
also now closing up this diagonal
it's very interesting if you try b4 if
you're wondering about b4 then knight to
e5
could be very strong now because it
attacks the rook and there's even a fun
line
queen captures on d4 and now bishop
captures on b4 you are
uh offering a queen trade then you're
offering the bishop but
lastly you will grab the rook uh sorry
that's not a rook the rook
and now after queen captures on b2 let's
say bishop captures an a8 you're going
to capture on b4
with check and now let's say queen to
you offer a queen trade and
it's a very fun position to play white
of course is up material
but black has this beautiful past c pawn
so uh could be uh you know
anything could happen but white is
better so black always
avoids this so after this a4 idea uh
like i said we have
c6 and now comes queen to c2 uh dubo
continues developing we have bishop to
b7 magnus does the same
and now h4 duval again going for his
h4h5h6ids and
uh probably not going for castles uh
king to f1
is the is the new castle so knight beat
the d7
and now h5 and now magnus of course
doesn't want to see h6 on the board so
he pushes
h6 himself and now knight to e5 putting
a double attack here on the c6 pawn and
offering a trade in the center
so magnus closes at knights to d5 now
now blocking this bishop on g2 and here
uh rook to h4 by dubois and this is so
interesting
uh because duval is already leading the
match so there's no point
for him to try and play aggressively and
you know try and
win another game against magnus but
that's exactly what he's doing now he
has his rook on h4
and his king will be very safe on f1 or
g1 depending on what black plays so here
magnus continues improving his pieces
knight seven to f6
and now king to f1 by dubo so a nice uh
move with the king queen to c7 magnus
connects rooks uh
well not not not just yet he makes room
for for example a queenside castle if
needed
uh but also he can castle king's side uh
so king to g1 by dubaf
and now comes knight to b4 attacking
dooba's queen and if
double wants he can eliminate the knight
here but of course he doesn't he goes
back
queen to c1 uh and now rook the d8 so
magnus decides he is not castling
queenside could be dangerous after all
of this opens up
uh and here double plays a captures on
b5 he wants to open up the a file
and bring his rook to a7 but there was
actually a very forcing line b3
it's a very sneaky move because after
the pawn is captured
you then capture on b5 and now it's very
dangerous black cannot recapture because
the queen will be hanging here and
there's a triple attack here
here here and here so you're just going
to remove one of the defenders
and create a beautiful pass pawn for
example castles you're just going to
eliminate one of the defenders and then
grab on c6 and it's a
really beautiful pass pawn so this was
in the position for duba
okay black also has a past b pawn but
after let's say this moves and rook to
b1 going after the pawns
white's white's pass pawn is is much
stronger here so after rook d8 with a
capture sun b5 dubo goes for a different
line he just wants to get his rook
up to a7 and c captures on b5 oh sorry
c captures uh on b c captures on b5 we
have bishop captures on b4
grabbing that knight a captures on b4
and now
rook to a7 so this is why dooba went for
this line instead of
investigating on that all whole b3
action
idea thingy uh so rook to a7 now with a
double attack on the bishop here
the bishop and the rook are attacking it
and magnus needs to defend it so you
could try it with rook to b8 but then
you might run into some bishop the c6
check uh sneaky idea so magnus once
again brings his knight back to d5 and
blocks the light square bishop and this
is the absolute best move
but now as the defender of the g4 square
has left uh
rook to g4 now attacking the g7 pawn
rook to g8 and now queen to c2 again the
rook moved
from h8 so now the h file has been
vacated for the queen queen to c2 now
you can go even to h7
and here magnus says okay that's all
very nice but it's not
actually doing anything so let me just
push my pawn c3
i'm going to create a pass pawn and your
pieces are very active but
i am not impressed is what magnus is
saying
so here uh queen to h7 indeed is not all
that impressive just rook f8 and the
queen doesn't really have all that much
to do sure you can grab
uh on g7 but um
that pawn there is just too strong c2
and you don't really have any threats
here this is defended three times
uh whereas black is just threatening to
bring another queen into the game
so after the c3 move dubo eliminates one
of the pawns b
captures b captures and now plays rook
to a3 another option everyone was uh
going on in the chat about was rook to
f4 just putting more pressure on the f7
pawn as uh for example if the knight
captures then of course this falls
uh but it's not really all that
impressive uh either because after rook
to f8
there's not much to do if you capture
and d5 just rook captures
and black holes that holds this very
nicely
uh so duba instead went for a different
line he played rook to a3
now saying okay i'm definitely putting
more pressure on the c3 pawn i can
eliminate
the defender of the pawn then pick then
pick up the pawn and
magnus says okay i'm going to defend it
one more time and now
knight to d3 by do both he wants to get
his knight over
to c5 and magnus stops this with a very
nice idea he plays
knights to f6 attacking the rook and the
bishop he could play b4
as the b4 pawn would be protected but he
prefers knight to f6 now opening up an
attack on the rook
and on the bishop here uh and here uh
dubo
uh has some moves he can play he decides
to go bishop captures on b7 first
queen captures on b7 and now dubo needs
to find a good move that moving the rook
is a good move for example rook the uh
rook to f4 is a good move rook to h4
also can be moved
but the move do of played uh is uh
well both dubious and dubovius uh as he
played
knight to c5 and this is just complete
madness because now
magnus is kind of winning the game so
feel free to pause the video and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
yes the rook was indeed still hanging so
simply eliminate the attacker of the
queen and then pick up the rook yes
that's all there is to it
uh this is what dubois missed
unfortunately for him and magnus of
course found it magnus played rook
captures on c5
i'm sure all of you found it as well so
congratulations on that d
captures on c5 and now magnus just grabs
a rook
and this is an amazing position because
magnus has
a lot of pawns here he's up a knight his
position is
a great okay his king is still in the
center but uh
a lot of people would resign in this
position but not to do both
uh kept his cool he considered the
position for
like a minute minute and a half maybe
even two minutes i wasn't really paying
attention
and he just played c6 and here we've
reached a position from the thumbnail
and this is something that i really
enjoy uh in dubose games that i
really often uh not often always enjoyed
in the games of me
of the great mikhail tal uh that uh
you know try try and good things will
happen here dubo indeed tries he plays
pawn to c6 attacks carlson's queen and
already a sub-optimal move from
magnus magnus captures on c6 where
queen to b6 attacking the f2 pawn uh
would have been much stronger for
example if e3 defending just b4
and black's position is now uh just uh
a monstrosity for example even if you go
something like uh
rook to a8 with check just kink the e7
and now you get into this very tricky
position where if you capture an uh
g8 b3 is coming and it's just a complete
madness for example queen captures here
you're going to go
b2 and uh black is getting another queen
into the game it is
it looks very dangerous but it's just
you know really really crazy
but magnus instead of going queen to b6
he captured the pawn which is not
uh all that bad in itself but it is much
much worse than this
uh queen to b6 idea uh gives up the c3
pawn double grabs it and now
queen to b6 now magnus goes after the f2
pawn
e3 by do both and now the only uh
winning move is still for magnus king to
e7 and magnus plays it
now if he can get his rook into the game
then he's just up a piece and then he's
just gonna crush do both
so double needs to stop that however he
can double plays rook to c6
attacks carlson's queen we have queen
back to d8
and now queen to c5 with check
preventing the queen from blocking as
both the queen and the rook attack
that's
sorry attack that square and here magnus
went king to f6
it's the only good move for black and
now there is no easy way for dubo to
continue the attack
or rather there's no way unless you try
and make something happen out of nothing
and here duboff plays
rook to d6 so carlson's queen is under
attack
and he needs to do something but it's
not all that easy to make a move here
uh here uh a a good move would be
something like queen to a5 you could
also go queen to c8 queen to a8
but queen to a5 with the idea of queen
the e1
check and again winning the f2 pawn and
checkmating the black king
uh is is a viable plan and it allows you
to bring the rook into the game however
here magnus just played queen to e7
because it seems like it also gets the
job done now
the rook cannot move otherwise the queen
is lost you can bring the rook here
now for example attack the rook twice
everything seems to be working well for
magnus
but the problem is there is a winning
idea here for
for do both and duba finds it he plays
queen to d for
check king the g5 and now although it
looks very scary it seems like carlson's
king is safe in fact
it's not feel free to pause the video
here and win the game for duba while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations
on spotting that if the queen was on g4
it would indeed be checkmate so
congratulations to everyone who found it
and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's f3 now
this
really becomes a threat and queen
captures and g4 is an
unstoppable thread of checkmate because
for example if you move the knight
then queen to e5 is checkmate the knight
from g4 was guarding the e5 square
so that's out of the question so here
after this f3 move carson thought
thought about the position for a moment
he doesn't have a lot of time also
so he played f5 he said okay i'm going
to give back the piece but at least i'm
surviving here
dubo captured the piece and here uh you
cannot capture back because then queen
e5 is again
checkmate so magnus had to go back or
rather he played
rook the c8 now finally the rook comes
into the game and now
maybe magnus can continue playing this
because he's still up upon
but now it's just a forced checkmate in
two and what a beautiful checkmate it is
duboff instantly finds it queen to f4
check
king to f6 and now of course you will
see it
queen captures on f5 with checkmate as
the pawn here
is pinned and that's just it the queen
covers all of these squares
carlson's king is checkmated and i mean
carlson is eliminated
from the tournament the duval goes into
the semi-finals
and this is just uh this was just a
beautiful beautiful match and every game
was just spectacular
i'm very happy that uh there is someone
in
in the top top 20 in the world that is
playing such
amazing chess uh you know constantly
attacking constantly creating madness on
the board is just uh
uh you know just a pure joy to watch
this
and interestingly i'm not gonna spoil
too much
uh no i'm not gonna spoil anything
rather better tell you in maybe the next
video
or some the video tomorrow uh but yeah
uh really amazing stuff dubo was able to
get
inside carlson's head because carlson
did get a winning position dubo
blundered terribly
but then it all came down to like there
were a lot of
uh positions where carlson maybe could
have done better
but this is where i was just uh like
insanely impressed like
here sorry and maybe i wanted a bit too
much
uh here like dooba just blunders a piece
completely
like this is the position and here he
just pushes c6 i mean
who does that this is uh just amazing
stuff how he found
such contra play uh because
it is in fact what led him to to a
position that
he was able to convert into a win so
really amazing stuff big congratulations
to dubai hope he
uh has many more games like this as you
know we're definitely going to cover all
of them on the channel since it's uh
this is this is quality chess and this
is what i know all of you guys enjoy
uh so yeah uh that's it uh for for this
match carlson is out dublin
goes into the uh semifinals i hope you
guys enjoyed it
magnus sure hasn't but he's gonna have
to try some other time
uh as he still has he still has a yet to
win a tournament
since he has since he turned 30 years
old uh but yeah
once again i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank david dawson david
kimura tom nagler
anna olila and james and adriana harper
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day